peace be with you welcome to the Deshawn
idiot hole subscribe if you haven't
already my next guest is in the front
line I'm trying to save lives because
heart disease is a leading killer in
America and you know who's a big fan of
his work that's right the former
President Bill Clinton have conquered
your wait what are you doing how do you
do it why can't I do it so when you and
I had to have our heart operations
because of blockage
you know dr. Esselstyn that who has the
most part of militant position he
doesn't even eat things made with olive
oil yeah and he looks great
he's about ten years older than we are
what we've heard from President Clinton
is the remarkable change that he's been
willing to make to remove completely
from his his nutrition
those foods which we know will devastate
and injure the inner lining of your
arteries and when we come back dr.
Esselstyn will be telling us how heart
disease can be cured how it can be
reversed here on the d show don't go
anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the D show and our
special guest because it's important
we're trying to save light from the
documentary forks over knives this could
be the first generation of children in
the United States that lives less than
its parents I got two pills I take for
my diabetes then I got one full of
cholesterol high blood pressure and then
I take my ADA which is an injectable dr.
Esselstyn how are you sir I'm fine how
are you today good thank God I was very
impressed I saw you actually our forks
over knives have you seen the
documentary most certainly yeah now I'm
looking at a book here
it's called reversing heart disease tell
it before we get into a book tell us a
little bit about yourself and what you
do well yeah after I finished my tour as
a combat surgeon in Vietnam I was asked
to join the staff of the Cleveland
Clinic where I was a general surgeon for
30 years I was director of the breast
cancer Task Force and head of the
section on thyroid and parathyroid
surgery but it was in my role as a
chairman of the breast cancer task force
that I got increasingly disillusioned in
the late 1970s early 80s with the fact
that no matter for how many women I was
doing breast surgery I was doing
absolutely nothing for the next
unsuspecting victim and this led to a
bit of global research and it was quite
striking to see that breast cancer rates
for example in Kenya were something like
30 and 40 times less frequent than in
the United States and if you looked at
breast cancer in rural Japan in the
1950s it was very infrequently
identified and yet as soon as the
Japanese women would migrate to the
United States for the second and third
generation
still cured Japanese American they now
have the same rate of breast cancer as
their Caucasian counterpart and even
more provocative perhaps was the
incidence of prostate cancer in the
entire nation of Japan in 1958
how many autopsy proven cases were there
cancer deaths from cancer of the
prostate in Japan 18 one of the most
mind-boggling 66 you've ever seen dr.
Esselstyn can you can you tell us for
the audience most people have no idea
what heart disease is what causes heart
disease and can we start from the
beginning can you tell us what actually
is what is heart disease the leading
killer of women and men in Western
civilization is coronary artery heart
disease and if the truth be known this
is really nothing more than a toothless
paper tiger that need never ever exist
and if it does exist and they never ever
progressed this is a benign foodborne
illness and I say that because if we
look for instance at some of the
cultures on the planet today like the
rural Chinese the Papo Highlanders a
central Africa or the Tarahumara Indians
in northern Mexico a kind of vascular
disease is virtually non-existent in
these cultures why because by heritage
and tradition they consume a plant-based
type of nutrition and this is really so
they're the guideposts so much of the
research that we were involved in when
the first our first small study in 1985
when I was initiated this started with
patients who were absolutely ravaged
with heart disease and we asked them to
in essence stop the foods that were
injuring the lining of their artery
every time that passed their lips I mean
I think all experts in this disease
would agree that where this disease has
its inception is what we progressively
destroy that life jacket and guardian of
our
vessels which is that single layer of
cells that lines the innermost part of
our artery the endothelium and the
endothelial cells manufacture this
wonderful magic molecule of gas nitric
oxide nitric oxide protects and prevents
all the cellular elements in our
bloodstream from ever getting sticky our
blood flows like Teflon rather than
velcro number two nitric oxide is the
strongest vessel dilator in the body
when you climb stairs the arteries to
your higher widen the artery is sturdy
legs widen and dilate that's nitric
oxide number three nitric oxide protects
the wall of the artery from becoming
thickened stiff or inflamed it protects
us from getting high blood pressure or
hypertension number four and this is
most important that an adequate safe
amount of nitric oxide will protect us
from ever developing blockages or plaque
so in other words everyone huh everyone
on the planet who has cardiovascular
disease has their disease because they
have so sufficiently trashed and injured
their endothelial capacity to make
nitric oxide they don't have enough
nitric oxide to protect themselves from
developing this disease so what are the
foods that every time you pass these
foods pass your lips you injure your
endothelial cell and decrease the
production of nitric nitric nitric oxide
they are oils olive oil corn oil soybean
oil safflower sunflower coconut oil palm
oil oil in a cracker oil and a piece of
bread oil and salad dressing oil will
injure the endothelial cell number two
anything with a mother or a face meat
fish chicken fowl turkey poultry well
injure endothelial cells as does dairy
no cream butter cheese ice cream and
yogurt and
any excesses of sugars such as maple
syrup molasses and honey and so what we
found interestingly enough if you do the
research going back to nineteen to 1950s
and look at sadly our GIS who died in
combat in Korea you will find that 80
percent of those 20 year old GIS had
gross evidence of coronary artery
disease already not enough for their
cardiac events yet but there the disease
was already established now on the other
hand if you look at a similar autopsy
study now 45 years later in 1999 this
time looking at young women and men
between the age of 17 and 34 you will
find that now the diseases ubiquitous
everybody has the disease so what's
going on here again not enough at that
young age
to have their cardiac events so not
surprisingly that people keep eating
these same Western foods and it
continued to interest not surprising
that we as physicians then identify
their cardiac events which begin
occurring in their 40s 50s and 60s and
so on now what we found actually 30
years ago in our first small group of
patients who had serious cardiovascular
disease and they had failed their first
or second bypass and they had failed the
first to second angioplasty or they were
too sick for these procedures they had
refused and we found that when they were
instructed to limit their nutrition to
whole food plant-based nutrition not
only could they stop the progression of
their disease but they could also we
would see at times striking examples of
disease reversal so are you are you
saying now that you can reverse this
heart disease which by the way how many
people actually die from
heart disease yearly do you know the
numbers is this what is this is this
true it's one of the is it the leading
cause of death every year absolutely yes
so are you saying doctor assisting that
you don't have to be on ten different
forms of drugs pharmaceutical drugs that
you can actually reverse this because
some doctors will say this is a myth but
are you saying this is a fact that you
can reverse it without the drugs and
with a plant-based diet let's do this
let's go over the totality of the
evidence I've shared with you already
from an epidemiological standpoint that
there are millions of people who will
never develop cardiovascular disease now
what we found out thirty years ago is
but he took these patients who were
seriously ill with cardiovascular
disease and by getting them to eat the
same type of whole food plant-based diet
that we see in those nations where the
disease is not present not only could
they stop their disease but often you
would see striking examples of disease
reversal dr. Ornish my colleague and
friend was a pioneer at this and
published studies before we did and
there are increasingly is there an
awareness of the fact that this is a
benign foodborne illness I've often said
that coronary artery diseases of
toothless paper tiger that need never
ever exists and if it does exist it need
never ever progressed this is a
completely benign
who would born illness for example we
just reported another paper last year of
some to 198 patients where there was a
adherence rate of our program of close
to ninety percent eighty nine percent of
those patients who adhere to the program
over the next three point seven five
years there was one major cardiac event
one patient had a stroke that's ninety
nine point four percent avoided any
further cardio basket is that events and
these are patients who had severe triple
vessel coronary artery disease now when
I say reversal I think it's important to
recognize that what most people will
think about is the blockages that occur
in the major coronary arteries and yes
you can see sometimes striking example
of reversal of of that but there are our
patients who are in their 50s and 60s
and so forth who will have plaque that
is made up of scar fibrosis and
calcification that even though that will
never reverse these patients
interestingly enough can reverse their
stress test can reverse their disease on
a PET scan meaning that they can get
practically normal flow back to the
heart muscle without reversing that that
plaque in the major artery in addition
to that there may be disease in the legs
there may be disease in the carotid
artery going to the brain you can see
reversal in that irh of the brain with
ultrasound in the leg you can see the
transition when you measure their
difference in calcium and then there are
multiple symptoms that will change as
these patients reverse their disease
they get they will escape their angina
their chest pain it will get rid of
their claudication or pain in the calf
muscle if it is due to disease in any
extremity or they will actually reverse
their erectile dysfunction we're here
with dr. Esselstyn we're going to take a
break we're here trying to save some
lives man on the front line trying to
cut this statistic down because it is a
leading killer heart disease we'll be
right back with more don't go anywhere
I want you to imagine you wake up and in
front of you are a bunch of guys running
around kicking a ball no goals no lines
no rules what would you think but is
that your life surely every sport has
its goal every game has its end
it has its objective it has its rules
how about life how about our life isn't
there a goal to life
isn't there a purpose an objective that
we have to reach we think so the Koran
tells us that we exist in order to
worship God and worshiping God means
knowing God as the Quran says when the
holocrons in the will insert allure leah
badoon worship though is not some narrow
small thing its wide its vast it
encompasses everything that the human
being does everything that you do
everything that you think everything
that you feel can be done thought said
felt in a way that is either pleasing or
displeasing to God the purpose of life
is to try and do everything in a way
that God loves and God is pleased with
that is your goal please subscribe to
the DCO follow us on our official
Facebook and Twitter pages in the links
below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show were dr. Esselstyn
sir we we saw now on the on the movie
that you were in the film that actually
the people they were written off by
their their doctors that basically they
were going to die and is it true that
they were it shows us in the film that
they were actually taken off the
prescription drugs they actually ended
up living and all through this the
natural way through this changing up
their eating diet and going more on a
plant-based diet is this right well
that's that sure the patient just that
we're seeing in the film and had a very
gratifying response they were people who
told that they brought into their whole
concept a whole food plant-based
nutrition and they actually were
delighted and proud to to be a part of
it but as soon as they start losing
their chest pain they lose weight they
see that their disease is reversing I
mean you've got them hooked it is is
incredible to think that something as
simple as nutrition could be so
absolutely powerful I mean the trouble
with most physicians who treat
cardiovascular disease is not only are
they carrying their compassionate and
they have an enormous fund of knowledge
but no time in their training were they
ever exposed to the power of nutrition
they don't understand nutrition they
never get training in it they don't get
training in behavioural modification and
so they are it's very difficult for them
to embrace it but one of the things that
we have found increasingly is that many
younger cardiologists who are willing to
take a look at this have absolutely
embraced it and have done wonderful
things with their patients as they begin
to teach them the power of plant-based
nutrition what are the foods that they
must avoid what are the foods that will
restore their healthy vasculature my
uncle he's a medical doctor he's
actually he knows about you he's a fan
of your work and he's on board I got to
talk to him a little bit about this
about most of the doctors not embracing
more of this natural plant-based
remedies for healing but he he he had
seemed to have said that you know we we
we do it we we know and most of them
have no cool about nutrition so what do
you do he's actually on board now he's
uh he actually has the book he's
referring patients to change up their
diet and what do you actually do when
you when you encounter people in the
medical profession because we want to
get them on board well that's right as I
often said in my presentation as regards
if those who are specialists in
cardiovascular medicine it really is
possible for the best to be even better
and what we do is over the last five
years once a month I conduct an
intensive counseling seminar five and a
half hours for patients who do
cardiovascular disease and during that
time these patients are going to learn
exactly what they did to create the
disease in the first place and precisely
how they can become empowered as the
locus of control to halt and to reverse
their disease and at the same time
everybody who attend and this is going
to receive a very hefty notebook that
has every one of my PowerPoint slides
that I will have use several of our
peer-reviewed scientific articles
because when you think about it what
really is going to make this transition
confluent inescapable is the absolute
science of this approach they also get a
44 page handout with many additional
recipes to add to the 240 which are only
two books that we conclude include and
also there's a marvelous hour and a
quarter presentation from a wonderful
woman who said 30 years experience
acquiring and preparing plant-based
foods dealing with reading ingredients
and dealing with travel in the
restaurants and then everybody receives
a DVD of the entire five and a half hour
seminar so that if they get home and
forgetful they can accept this on and
get themselves back up to speed and then
we always have three local or regional
participants who previously had a
successful experience share their story
so that those in attendance can say to
themselves listen if he or she can do
this I can do this and then we have time
I'm through answering questions like
Legion and then we stay in touch as
necessary either through email or phone
call now the interesting thing is
getting back to the gang of other
physicians to become familiar with this
and the last five years we've had 125
physicians attend our course because
they were interested in what we were
doing and it's very gratifying to see
those some of that begin to incorporate
this
in their own practice doesn't this go
back to the statement I'm sure you're
familiar with Hippocrates who said let
food be your medicine and medicine be
your food sounds pretty good
tell us about you put your personal let
us just for a moment get into your a one
day with dr. Esselstyn when you wake up
in the morning what do you eat how many
times a day do you eat some of your your
your entrees that you have throughout
the day can you please fill us in well
actually tell you what I eat would be
better to have my wife works but I the
cereal I love in the morning is I love
old fashioned oats and I don't like to
cook them I use an item as a dry cereal
form in the bowl then add some raisins
and a banana for some sweetness then I
like to add raspberries blueberries and
strawberries and I particularly like to
wet it down with oat milk and I find
that's very delicious and it carries me
very well till 12:30 one o'clock when I
may have lunch
what is lunch lunch made is use
frequently is a sandwich which is a mess
similar type of rye bread with a hummus
spread on it and then some cut-up
scallions or cilantro or some kale it
has been cooked five and a half minutes
it was nice and tender and then maybe
anointed with some lemon juice now on
top of that will be an enormous slice of
tomato so I have an open sandwich and on
top of the tomato I'll have some a
tasteful balsamic vinegar and several of
those hold me nicely for lunch then for
supper I would have to say that the
all-time favorite and the meal that I
first encountered in Puerto Rico over 31
years ago when we were transitioning was
old fashioned beans and rice beans and
rice with some cut-up scallions
peppers cut up Tomatoes peas corn and
maybe have some water chestnuts and on
top of that you can anoint it with
either tamari or some salsa and you've
got an absolute feast now we here right
now president former President Clinton
saying you know dr. Esselstyn that who
has the most for a militant position he
doesn't even eat things made with olive
oil yeah and he looks great he's about
ten years older than we are but he has a
piece of chocolate every New Year's Eve
that you fudge once a year is that right
oh you don't want to go Kay back with
more with dr. Esselstyn don't go
anywhere
ladies and gentlemen this is your
captain speaking
welcome aboard flight five two three
five non-stop to London Heathrow the
temperature is 25 degrees outside and we
are expecting a fairly smooth flight
today in a few moments the flight
attendants will be passing around the
cabin to offer you hot and cold drinks
we thank you for choosing to fly with us
today and we hope you enjoy your flight
thank God it was just a dream good I
don't believe in God ladies and
gentlemen the captain has turned on the
fasten seatbelt sign
[Music]
[Music]
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
on the D show with dr. Esselstyn here
we're trying to cut that now you said
it's 800,000 people die from heart
disease yearly no I said 800,000 people
die from cardiovascular disease that
includes strokes and heart attacks and
heart attacks now heart disease is
somewhat of a silent killer it can creep
up and get you and you can just you're
lucky if you get a second chance is that
right well there's no question that that
heart disease can be a very subtle at
times patients may not have anything in
the way of symptoms with a plaque that
is blocking their artery by no more than
30 or 40 percent and it's sadly that
plaque should rupture and then suddenly
the body tries to mend that rupture by
laying down a clot now suddenly a vessel
which was 30 percent block is now a
hundred percent blocked and that means
that all the downstream heart muscle is
suddenly deprived of oxygen and
nutrients and it dies and that's the
heart attack and sometimes these heart
attacks can result in it what we call it
cardiac arrhythmia where the heart goes
into a ventricular rhythm which will
lead to fibrillation or standstill which
is fatal and how is it true you actually
after this this operation where you take
what is the devayne from the from the
leg you put it inside the you open up
the chest and you do the the bypass
surgery you haven't still fixed the
problem have you it's a temporary
solution all even kind of vascular
surgeons are the first to admit it
just like cardiologists who are doing
sense
[Music]
thing position illness and her is study
after study after so that if you are
having a stent while you're in the
middle of a heart attack but still can
be absolutely really like say you save a
lot of your heart muscle from damage
your life however what about the other
90% that are having week off you look to
extent with elective stance when you're
in Santa Cruz you got some chest pains
or you may have a less best test there
is no problem well it's new and there
really no protection from the future
heart attack and thank you dr. Esselstyn
for being with us here on the Dean show
forgive us for the technical
difficulties and get the book preventing
reversing heart disease you know what it
is a serious matter
you have this leading killer killing too
many people and we can go ahead and
fight this by putting by fighting our
urges to eat the wrong foods and
changing our ways and eating the right
foods and God willing with God's help we
can go ahead and take advantage of all
the wonderful beautiful foods that are
out there all of the green beautiful
vegetables the fruits and getting away
from all this junk that's out there and
when you put junk in what do you get
junk out so God willing you can go ahead
and make these modifications these
adjustments is in our lives so we can go
ahead and live a more fruitful
well-balanced life we'll see you next
time here in the Dean show until then
subscribe if you haven't already peace
be with you there's no question that if
the truth were known that coronary
artery disease is a toothless paper
tiger that need never exist and if it
does exist it need never ever progress
what we've heard from President Clinton
is the remarkable change that he's been
willing to make to remove completely
from his his nutrition those foods which
we know will devastate and injure the
inner lining of your arteries
and the remarkable thing is the capacity
the body has to heal itself and when you
do what President Clinton has done will
you completely try to remove any foods
that are going to injure your vessel the
Bart body has this remarkable capacity
begin to heal itself and I'm afraid that
as a medical profession we perhaps have
fallen down and really emphasized too
much the drugs and the procedures and
the operations which really treat the
symptoms they do not treat the causation
of this illness this is one of the few
times since Hippocrates that we have not
told patients about the causation of
their illness